[Music]
samantha's in houston hi samantha
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
so my husband and i have about 150 000
worth of debt
90 000 of which is car loans um
yes it's insane um
we
have talked about
selling our vehicles i went to
some places and got an appraisal
um both of us are quite upside down on
the vehicles you must roll some negative
equity from the other deal into it
yes well i guess so i mean when i traded
my car in i thought that i was right on
par but i was not and my husband knew he
was negative
um so we i went to my credit union i
asked them to roll the negative into a
personal loan they denied me two
different times
i am just at a loss what to do right now
our car notes are
extremely high
so tell me about car number one what is
it
okay so car number one my husband's
truck uh the loan on that is 53 000
and um it's a ford f-150 the car payment
is one thousand thirty four dollars good
god
all right and um what the uh uh what did
they tell you that that was worth
um they're telling us that it's about
twenty thousand negative so thirty three
thousand is the value of this how many
miles on it oh this is truck
yes uh the how many miles i believe it's
about forty thousand miles
how old is what year is the truck
twenty nineteen
go to kellybluebook.com yeah that's
garbage that's bull crap that's a dealer
offer did you get more than one place to
look at this
uh yes i he went to um
a ford dealership and he's also talked
to carmax
i talked to carmax today actually and
got an appraisal on mine i'd probably
got to tell you about that next okay um
that sounds very low in this market for
sure used cars are still selling very
high i would check kellybluebook.com and
start looking at a private sale i'm
shocked to hear that a 2019 is 20 grand
upside down now he rolled some negative
into it to start with you said that but
that's a lot okay and then and your car
then is what
it's a 2020 ford explorer um the
car that the loan that i that i owe is
36 thousand
uh payment is 573 a month
and today i got an appraised at carmax
for
27.5
okay well that means you can get uh 32
for it private sale probably so that
one's that one's within striking range
what's your um
meaning you could go get that other 4
000 out of your income in the next few
months uh what's your income
our income is 140 000. that's good news
okay all right yeah i'm sorry yours is
probably going first because it's easier
to get rid of
right
because it's closer i'm also going to
check the numbers because i want to make
sure he didn't just not want to sell his
truck
oh i i don't think that's what it is but
but yes please check
it's just it's like those numbers just
don't feel i mean i haven't pulled it up
and looked at it but that feels awfully
wrong but yeah you're right a thousand
dollar and a six hundred dollar car
payment those are two good things to get
rid of
and get to get you a hoop a couple of
hoopties because y'all been doing stupid
car disease for a long time bless your
heart i'm sorry you are stuck in a mess
you have identified the problem kiddo
and now the trick is to get out of it
you do any good over there yeah let me
tell you right now private market is
where they need to be looking they're
getting a dealer offer oh yeah it's
trade-in value yeah but the truck did it
did you find anything on it yeah i found
some stuff you're looking at 45 to 55
000
for that i didn't think 33 was right
okay